the chicky science show clips
so the best place to start is with nad
itself so nad stands for nicotinamide
adenine dinucleotide and this is one of
the most abundant molecules in the human
body it is important not only as a
coenzyme for different redox reactions
and for energy metabolism but also as an
essential co-factor for different
enzymes notably the sertoin family and
polyadp-ribose polymerases known as pops
that are important in dna repair but it
is thought that there are more than 300
enzymes relying on nad plus for their
activity so i think we can say that nad
plus is pretty important however nad
plus levels have been shown to decline
as we age when there's high amounts of
dna damage which is partly due to the
activation of these parp enzymes and due
to certain activity and also during
alcohol metabolism and so for these
different reasons there's a lot of
interest at the moment in trying to
restore nad plus levels to alleviate
some of the symptoms associated with nad
plus decline but before we go into some
of these methods we really need to
understand energy metabolism and how it
works otherwise what i say could just
sound like a load of gibberish so in my
opinion the best way to understand it is
to understand why nad plus is called
nicotinamide adenine dinucleotides and
that can be seen by looking at its
structure where i've indicated different
groups of the compounds and where the
name comes from so the first part
nicotinamide comes from the fact that it
has this nicotinamide group attached to
a ribose molecule the second ribose
molecule in nad plus is attached to an
adenosine group hence the nicotinamide
adenine aspects of the name and then the
last part dinucleotide refers to the
fact that these two ribose molecules are
attached through two phosphates and this
is similar to the backbone of nucleic
acids and so each nucleic acid is
otherwise referred to as a nucleotide
until you've got a dinucleotide present
and so the reason i went to so much
detail here isn't because i love
biochemistry which i obviously do but
because it helps us to understand how
nad plus is generated and then consumed
within a cell and so it's thought that
there are three different pathways
within a cell that can generate nad plus
and these three pathways are nicely
summarized in this figure from a recent
review article on nad plus metabolism
which was a good source of information
for this video and so on the far left
you can see that there's the dinovi
pathway to nad plus formation that
starts from tryptophan tryptophan being
an amino acid as you can see there's
quite a few steps that take tryptophan
through to nat plus and for these
reasons some of the enzymes involved in
these steps aren't expressed in all cell
types and so we saw that this dnava
pathway is mainly occurring only in the
liver the second pathway to nhdplus is
from vitamin precursors known as
nicotinic acid or you might know it as
niacin and this gets converted to nad
plus via the prius handler pathway and
the last method is the so-called salvage
pathway which generates nad plus from
nicotinamide nam so if we go back to the
biochemical structure of nad plus that i
showed you earlier nicotinamide is just
this moiety group at the end that i've
indicated and the reason it's called the
salvage pathway is because when nad plus
is consumed by different enzymes within
the body such as sertalians and pops one
of the products is nicotinamide and so
nicotinamides can be converted back into
nadplus and therefore effectively rescue
the nad plus levels the way it's
converted back is by going through an
intermediate known as nmn nicotinamides
mononucleotide